hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game this time from round
5 of the 37th European Club cup now it
is Anton corbo versus Magnus Carlsen uh
yet another very very strong opponent on
the Magnus carlsen's path to 2900
classical ELO rating and if you've ever
seen Anton korob play you know that he's
just incredibly strong in any time
format uh so regardless of what you play
you will not have a good time playing
against this gentleman and in the
previous video we've shown again where
Anand and Mohamed Yaro just brawled it
out with 20 moves of known Theory then
Mommy they're prepared that exchange
sacrifice and they both played like
incredibly well like it was a really
really precise game but this game no
Theory I know that's that's your
favorite uh so we will have like three
moves of known Theory so Anton uh
quotable has the white pieces and he
opens with the D4 Magnus plays Knight to
F6 with Knight to F3 D5 and now Pawn to
E3 the so-called call system and here
Magnus plays a 6. now A6 is rare in
itself but korobof replies with a move
that is even rarer he plays Pawn to B3
now Magnus plays Bishop to F5 and now
there are a few games where Bishop to B2
was played but Anton plays a bishop to
A3 just think okay now you can't push
the E Pawn because I'm gonna mess up
your
uh castling and it is now as of move 5
that we have a completely new game so
what does Magnus do exactly that he
plays Pawn to E6 and he invites Anton to
capture an f8 which he does Bishop
captures King captures and now Bishop to
E2 so what is magnus's plan you might be
thinking okay he's going to play
something like G6 Buddha King and G7 and
Castle artificially not really he plays
Knight to C6 we have castles and now
just Pawn to H5 just uh in the style of
old Master just going full full
barbarian mode we have Pawn to C4 and
now Magnus pushes H4 and that was really
weirded out when I saw this because this
is how I play bullet uh Knight the C3
Anton playing just normal normal
positional chest and not Knight the E
for my Magnus you know put your pieces
as close to the opponent's king as
possible we have Rook to C1 and already
it's move 11 Magnus does a rook lift
Rook to H6 Now The Rook can go to G6 and
put even more pressure on the white king
so here we we have C characters on D5
Anton exchanges a pair of Pawns he
captures and the Knights the D2
continuing very nicely with the
positional play Magnus captures on C3
Rook captures and queen to D6 now
putting more pressure on yeah on Black's
position and now regardless of what the
engine says it's uh I mean I don't know
I guess it's pretty clear of which which
pieces you you prefer here but okay uh
Queen to C1 are very nicely played by
Anton uh just uh paralyzing that Knight
if the Knight moves then Rook captures
on C7 will be devastating so Magnus
figures it out he plays Rook to E8 and
after Bishop to F3 now he just plays a
rook the E7 now the C7 Pawn is nicely
defended and the Knight can enter the
game and now how do you continue this
well uh one thing you should prevent is
Magnus pushing H3 it's just a very nasty
move so you can play something like H3
and now I've rooked the G6 threatening
some Bishop captures an H3 action you
can play King to H1
uh just get up out of Harm's Way and now
it would be up to Magnus to decide how
he would continue playing this uh the
engine interestingly gives the top line
as a repetition of moves King H2 Queen
D6 checking stage 1.7 and King to H2 uh
but uh I mean uh who who would play
something like this so Anton plays
something very interesting he plays Rook
to C5 with the clear idea uh that the
bishop on F5 is undefended and he
prepares something special but Magnus
says uh your special your specialty does
not work with me and he just goes Knight
to B4 and this should have been
prevented now the Knight has access to
the D3 square and this is a problem but
okay this is Anton's plan Knight to C4
attacks the queen and now if Magnus
captures a dangerous root captures on F5
and everything is perfectly fine for
white
uh but instead Magnus just moves the
queen queen to E6 and okay the Knight is
still hanging so uh the problem is you
can't really play Knight the E5 because
then F6 traps the Knight so the Knight
has to go back so here we have knighted
the B2 and now the the incredible Pawn
to H3 and of course uh G3 and now Magnus
just grabs a pawn and attacks Anton's
Queen on C1 so Queen to D2 and the now
comes Bishop to E4 as Anton weakened the
light squares and a trade of a light
Square Bishop will go a long way then
Magnus would have some Queen E4 queen
queen G2 checkmating ideas so Anton
moves it back Bishop to E2 and now we
reach the position from the thumbnail
well almost the rook and C5 is in a
terrible spot because uh well the these
squares are covered by the Knight
discovered but Bishop discovered by the
pawn so here Magnus just plays B6 and
takes away the only two squares The Rook
had left and it seems like Anton can
just resign now but that's why chess is
such an interesting game of course Anton
did not resign Anton played Knight the
A4 and he created this very very tricky
position on the board that you guys will
have to solve so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
best continuation for Magnus while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not grabbing the
rook and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is actually moving
the bishop somewhere here or here or
here besties here this is where Magnus
put it as it's not going to get into in
the way of failure pieces regarding of
the line that caught above plays uh the
problem with capturing The Rook is that
okay you captured The Rook but then
Knight captures attacks the queen and
you will also win the night back so it's
not as great and the Knight gets this
beautiful Outpost for example Queen F5
you're just gonna capture Queen
characters on A2 and it's not as clear
uh how you are going to continue this
and you will not be checkmating white
anytime soon if you play something like
Bishop to F3 if you want to trade just
Bishop to D3 attacks the black queen so
there is counter play here so for those
of you who found Bishop back to H7 or F5
or G6 is fine H7 is the best uh
congratulations as you are truly a
master of attacking chess now of course
if the Knight is captured then Magnus
had planned Queen to E4 and here you
just resigned the only defense would be
to play F3 but that's really no defense
just captures with check you have to
play Rook F2 to guard the bishop now
beat characters and C5 The Rook cannot
be captured any of Knight captures on C5
just Queen captures on D4 and good luck
finding a move here there are even
tricks okay the Knight is saying let's
say B4 even Bishop to B1 attacking the
queen to grab the bishop on E2 and it's
the only move you have as all of these
squares are covered by the queen and by
the bishop so let's say captures Rook
captures now threatens the capture here
Queen F1 and your queen will be stuck
here let's say okay too for the rest of
the game it will be a very sad game for
white but you can play it so after
Bishop to H7 Anton instead plays Rook to
E1 and the situation on the clock is
some nine minutes for Anton in 20
minutes for Magnus the idea is that okay
Anton knows that he will have to play F3
but maybe he can continue fighting this
so Magnus goes Queen to E4 again you
can't just capture on C5 if you capture
on C5 then Knight cap represent C5 and
after Queen to F5 there's Queen captures
an A2 again
it's not that clear how to how to win
this with black so instead uh we have
Queen to E4 by Magnus now just
threatening Checkmate forcing F3 and now
Queen captures on E3 with check Queen
captures Rook captures and now there's
really not all that much the position is
just completely winning uh and also if
you guys were wondering uh after Queen
E4 if you have to believe F3 when at
Bishop to F1 guarding Checkmate uh
because then The Rook can be captured as
now after Knight captures on C5
attacking the queen there's Queen C2 the
bishop now guards the queen here and you
will not be winning the Knight on A2 so
okay after Queen E4 F3 captures the
queen trade is on the board you know
there's really not um not a good move
inside I don't played Rook captures on
C7 but just not Rook to E6 goes after
the bishop Here and Now King to F2
nicely defending but the position plays
itself Magnus goes Bishop to D3 and now
Hunter will have to give up some
material here if he doesn't want to give
up a piece he's going to have to give up
the exchange so Bishop captures Rook
capture Sunny one winning the exchange G
for now but just Knights the B4 Magnus
introduces the Knight back into the game
uh Bishop to F5 attacks the rook and now
Rook one to E2 sorry Rook one to E2 with
check King to G3 and not Magnus goes
Rook to D6 also possible is just Rook G2
you give up this pawn and then you just
destroy the white king this way uh
Magnus went the other way around he
played Rook D6 now comes Rook to B7
putting pressure on the B Pawn but now
G6 attacking the bishop and after the
bishop moved to D7 now just spawn to G5
and he was in this position on move 34
that Anton korbo resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the the V6 Pawn of course cannot be
captured because well The Rook is stuck
guarding the bishop on D7 and you really
don't have a movie you can play if you
go for King capture some H3 then you
just gets checkmated Rook H6 check and
after King G3 Rook e captures an H2 and
now this will just be Checkmate
regardless of what white plays another
thing you might try spawn to F4 but it's
also not great it just captures captures
Knight to D3 with check let's say King
G5 number of captures on H2 you move the
Rook you push the pawn you promote it to
a queen easy win there are no threats
here for for white
so really an incredible attacking game
by Magnus just went all out I mean every
every move was an attacking move from
this East is just allowing a quarterback
to spoil his uh castling then just H5 H4
Knight comes the E for the The Rook lift
comes into the game I mean such a such a
wild wild attacking game and Anton
played it well up until this Rook the C5
move he wanted to get out of it uh
tactically win a nice H3 would probably
hold the position better but yeah Magnus
really surprised him uh nicely and
another game by Magnus played in the
style of Old Masters I love it I hope we
see more and with the black pieces again
such a strong player like Anton korogov
so that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it the Magnus improves his
reigning he gained now like he's like up
plus three and a half so he is um you
know again uh going forward in his quest
the 2900 classical rating we'll see how
it goes I mean it's uh it's it's it's a
big Quest so again hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Antebellum eh
music Jose Palacio Chris Mullen and GJ
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check
out my new wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day